أوكرانيا تقول إن روسيا شنت أكبر
هجوم جوي لها منذ بدء الحرب مما أسفر عن مقتل
18 شخصًا على الأقل قال الرئيس الأوكراني
فلاديمير زالينسكي إن روسيا
استخدمت تقريبًا كل أنواع الأسلحة،
وصواريخ كروز، والطائرات بدون طيار، والقاذفات الاستراتيجية، وضربت
الهجمات الشرق والغرب
واستهدفت البنية التحتية المدنية
بما في ذلك المباني السكنية
ومستشفى للولادة تقول أوكرانيا إن
الهجمات تظهر أنها بحاجة إلى
دعم العالم. وجدد السفير الأمريكي في أوكرانيا
اليوم هذه الدعوة للحصول على
مساعدات عسكرية إضافية. وأعلنت وزارة الخارجية هذا
الأسبوع عن حزمة مساعدات بقيمة 250
مليون دولار. وبالطبع، عاد الكونجرس إلى بلاده
لقضاء عطلة العطلة.  دون
التوصل إلى اتفاق بشأن مزيد من
التمويل، سرعان ما أغرقت الانفجارات في جميع أنحاء أوكرانيا
الهواء صفارات الإنذار صباح يوم
الجمعة، وهو أكبر هجوم جوي روسي
منذ بدء الحرب وفقًا
للجيش الأوكراني الذي أحدث دمارًا على
الناس الذين كانوا هدفًا
لمراكب الكرملين لـ  ما يقرب من عامين
لم يتغير شيء هدف روسيا هو
نفسه تدمير أوكرانيا كدولة وتدمير
جميع الأوكرانيين المتمردين كأمة، أدى
الهجوم إلى مقتل العشرات في جميع أنحاء
أوكرانيا، وهو رقم يهدد بمواصلة
الارتفاع بينما يقوم عمال الإنقاذ بالحفر بين
الأنقاض لإخراج البعض أحياء و  بعضها
ليس في دينو، مزقت الصواريخ الروسية
مستشفى وجناح الولادة التابع له.
قال مسؤولون أوكرانيون إن
الاندفاع المحموم إلى ملاجئ الغارات الجوية أنقذ 12
امرأة حامل وأربعة أطفال حديثي الولادة
بالداخل الآن، هذا هو المكان الذي توجد فيه
غرف الولادة، هذا هو بالضبط الجانب من
المبنى الذي اشتعلت فيه النيران،
اعتقال روسيا للأسلحة الفتاكة التي ضربت العديد
من المدن الكبرى في أوكرانيا،
صواريخ كينسال التي تفوق سرعتها سرعة الصوت، وصواريخ مضادة للسفن من طراز s3000،
وطائرات بدون طيار من طراز "شهد" تم إطلاقها على كيف
دينبرو لافيف، والمزيد من الهجوم الذي جاء بعد
أيام فقط من إغراق أوكرانيا
لسفينة إنزال روسية في شبه جزيرة القرم، الوزارة الروسية
وقالت وزارة الدفاع إن السفينة تعرضت لأضرار
لكن المخابرات الدفاعية البريطانية قالت إن
السفينة دمرت ضربة أخرى
لأسطول الكرملين في البحر الأسود يوم الجمعة.
وقام الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير زالينسكي بزيارة مفاجئة إلى مدينة أديفا الواقعة على خط المواجهة
في شرق أوكرانيا متمنيا
لقواته ما قد يحدث.  يبدو من المستحيل
الآن عيد ميلاد سعيد وسنة
جديدة سعيدة، إنه أمر صعب، إنه الألم والخسائر وهؤلاء
هم الأشخاص الذين يبقون
أوكرانيا على قيد الحياة، ويتم النضال من أجل الحياة
هنا ونحن ممتنون لكل
محارب لكل جندي وبحار ورقيب
وضابط يتحمل هذا  الحرب على
أكتافهم أوكرانيا تدعو لمزيد من المساعدة
وزير الخارجية ديميترو كوبا يقول على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي إنه
يتمنى سماع الانفجارات في جميع
العواصم الكبرى والمقرات والبرلمانات
التي تناقش حاليًا المزيد من
الدعم لأوكرانيا هذا الأسبوع أعلنت الولايات المتحدة عن ما
يصل إلى 250 مليون دولار
حزمة أمنية لأوكرانيا لكنها
الشحنة الأخيرة ما لم يوافق الكونجرس على
طلب البيت الأبيض للحصول على 60 مليار دولار إضافية
لدعم كي، حث الرئيس جو بايدن
الكونجرس على التحرك يوم الجمعة قائلا إن
الهجوم الأخير دليل على أن بوتين يسعى
لمحو أوكرانيا وإخضاع
شعبها.  أوقف أورين ليبرمان
سي إن إن في واشنطن
العاصمة